Hi Pastor Mark we had a question come in
about signs and miracles. The question is
I keep asking God for a sign or miracle
to show he's near, but I received no
answer.
Why is God silent? Also, how do I keep
from getting discouraged when I get no
answer? That question is a very vital
question. What do you do when God seems
to be silent?
Many of the Bible characters had the
very same question and for them at times
God was silent. Let me give you an
example. Here is David in Psalm 28 verse
1 so you can almost hear David's cry to
you I will cry O Lord my rock do not be
silent to me lest if you are silent to
me I become like those who go down to
the pit hear the voice of my
supplications when I cry to you when I
lift up my hands towards your holy
sanctuary so here David says Lord it
seems that you're silent and when you're
silent I go down in the pit in other
words I get discouraged you look at
Daniel in Daniel chapter 10 the Bible
says Daniel prayed for three weeks no
apparent answer and he kept fasting for
three weeks he kept asking God for three
weeks but there was no answer but yet
the angel Gabriel comes to explain to
him what happened in fact first Jesus
came down to explain to him what
happened but then the angel Gabriel came
down and the angel Gabriel said Daniel
from the first day that you began to
pray I was there in answer to your
prayers this is a marvelous prayer in
Daniel chapter 10 it says Daniel 10
verse 2 in those days I Daniel was
mourning 3-4 weeks and I eat no Pleasant
bread he was in mourning he's fast for
these three weeks he lifts up his eyes
and finally at the end of three weeks
Jesus comes down Jesus brightness is so
great that Daniel faints and then verse
12 the angel Gabriel comes back to
Daniel to explain to him the issues and
he says they said to me don't fear
Daniel from the first day you set your
heart to understand and to humble
yourself before God your words were
heard and I've come because you
words Daniel did not see the answer to
his prayer there was no visible sign
that God was answering but God was there
the holy angels were beating back the
angels of hell over the mind of Cyrus to
let Daniel go free so it may be that God
is apparently silent but he is not
silent at all look around you see in the
love that you're receiving from your
family from a husband from a wife from a
sister from a brother from friends see
God there look around you at a home that
God has given you at children maybe that
God has given you look look around you
and see the blessings that God has given
you and see that God is there he's
bringing people into your life he's
answering your prayers
although unum may not see it the other
thing that I keep in mind is this in 1st
Corinthians chapter 10 I don't know what
you are going through but the Apostle
Paul puts it this way in 1st Corinthians
10 verse 13 he says there is no
temptation taken unto you but such as
common to man and God is faithful and
will not allow you to be tempted above
what you are able so whatever you're
going through today know that God is
there he is with you he's not going to
allow you to be tempted above what
you're able but the Bible goes on but
with the temptation will make a way of
escape that you can bear it so God is
gonna make that way of escape for you
that you will be able to bear this
temptation he's gonna bring you strength
and courage he may not work some
spectacular miracle but he will work in
your heart to give you strength and
courage in hope you remember after
Paul's experience on the Damascus Road
no doubt he experiences blindness not
only blindness but no doubt he
experienced pain quite sufficient pain
for the heat in his eyes and three times
he prayed to the Lord that it would be
delivered from him
and last second Corinthians 12 verse 7 8
9 lest I should be exalted above measure
by the abundance of revelations a thorn
in the flesh was given to me a messenger
of Satan now notice the thorn of the
flesh it's not given by God it's a
messenger of Satan verse 8 concerning
this thing I please plead with God three
times the Lord three times it might
depart from me and he said to me my
grace is sufficient for you my strength
is made perfect in weakness and Paul
says I'd rather boast in my infirmities
I take pleasure in my infirmities and
reproaches and needs and persecutions
for Christ's sake when I'm weak I'm
strong so here's what I would say to you
God is at work in your life whether you
see it or not
he was work at David's life and David
didn't see it he was work in Daniels
life Daniel didn't see it work in
Elijah's life but Elijah didn't see it
and in fact he lied you found himself in
a cave and God said what are you doing
here Elijah so God is at work in your
life ask God to give you divinely
anointed eyes to see what God is doing
all around you it may not be in some
loud spectacular miraculous way second
thing to keep in mind is this God will
never give you a test above what you are
able and God's grace is always
sufficient for you God will strengthen
you God will encourage you God will
enable you to get through whatever you
have to get through there is a third
thing to keep it remembrance and that is
this your strength in the trial that
you're going through will be comfort to
somebody else God will use you to try
you going through to draw you close to
him but I like what scripture says again
in Corinthians in first Corinthians the
Bible puts it this way first Corinthians
chapter 1 here is what the Apostle Paul
says he says blessed be the God that
comforts us in all of our tribulation
it's actually here in 2nd Corinthians
chapter 1 first
not first but second blessed be the God
and father of our Lord Jesus Christ the
father of mercies and the God of all
comforts of God is the God of all
comfort for you whatever you going
through who comforts us in all our
tribulation so in the tribulation he may
not deliver you from it but he's going
to give you comfort that we may be able
to comfort those who are in any trouble
with the comfort with which we received
ourselves from God so God allows us at
times to go through trials he
strengthens us in the trial gives us
comfort in it and then we're able to
comfort others so God can use your life
even within a sickness that you have
even if God doesn't work a miracle he's
there in your life to strengthen you to
encourage you to comfort you for why so
that you can comfort others so look away
from your trials to Jesus recognize that
he'll strengthen you recognize that he
is there with you look at the positive
things that are happening all around you
and sense that God is going to use you
to be a blessing to somebody else
you.